[Music]  [Music]  tokes a smile from the child remember  parents don't want to see a photo where  their child is not smiling sometimes a  child just does not want to smile it is  your job to coax the smile out of the  child a good line to remember is Santa  thinks everyone should be happy won't  you smile for Santa a photo can only  copy a child's smile it's gonna take you  to put it there now if the child's will  just absolutely not smile the photo elf  will take the picture anyway your  portrayal of this beloved character is  gonna make a major impression on every  child that you need keep in mind at all  times that to them you are not a man  dressed as Santa you are Santa okay  and a good Santa's job is to also smile  I know that the big white beard gets in  the way of the mouth area that's why you  have to learn how to smile with your  eyes they show a lot of warmth they can  be very expressive questions who's got a  question  [Music]